[Musique]
avec Bollène frad bonjour Hélène bonjour
Pauline et dans la presse bien sûr pour
commencer la qualification des Bleus
pour la finale de la coupe du monde de
foot après leur victoire face au Maroc
hier soir de zéro un exploit majuscule
avant un rendez-vous immense l'équipe le
quotidien sportif ça vous l'envoler
final des Bleus face à Maroc plein de
bravoure un exploit accompli notamment
grâce à la magnifique reprise de volley
de Théo Hernandez dès la 5ème minute
l'équipe de France vous l'avez dit
défendre à son titre dimanche face à
l'Argentine la quatrième finale de Coupe
du monde pour les Bleus en 24 ans on y
est encore et le Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France se réjouit de cette délicieuse
habitude offerte par les Bleus le
journal n'oublie pas de saluer au
passage le courage et l'abnégation
considérable des Lions de l'Atlas les
Français rêvent d'une troisième étoile
et la Marseillaise est d'humeur lyrique
c'est une quasi la palissade les ciels
d'hiver ne sont pas ceux d'été mais il
existe tout de même des étoiles visibles
toute l'année depuis à même endroit de
la terre elle répondent au nom d'étoiles
circumul polaire et celle dont les Bleus
sont en quête au Qatar et peut-être de
celle-là pour cela il faudra vaincre
donc l'Argentine de Lionel Messi un
combat qui s'annonce titanesque d'après
le délai express now brennington Messi
maintenant autour de mes sites titre ce
matin le tablier de britannique qui
visiblement a choisi son camp vous
l'avez dit Hélène après une incroyable
campagne la sélection nationale
marocaine a finalement échoué au pied de
la finale au bout d'un duel épique la
longue expérience des Bleus a eu raison
de l'ambition des Lions de l'Atlas mais
le matin quotidien marocain juge que la
sélection nationale s'en va la tête
haute les Lions ont définitivement
démontré leur capacité à tenir tête aux
géants mondiaux et cette dramatique
n'est peut-être que le début d'une
nouvelle ère pour le football marocain
espère le journal au-delà du Maroc
l'épopée des lions inspirés tout le
continent africain et le monde arabe qui
salue à l'image du quotidien émirati de
national la fierté des lions dans la
défaite le Maroc ne sera pas champion du
monde cette fois-ci mais dans une
tribune publiée par Le Monde Christiane
dardé dont le mari l'historien mathibe
monjib vite en liberté surveillée au
Maroc et ne peut pas quitter son pays
espère que l'espoir suscitait par les
footballeurs marocains réveillera aussi
le rêve que le champion devienne un jour
champion dans le domaine des libertés et
des droits humains la sociologue
rappelle que les quatre dates à la
liberté d'expression ce sont multipliés
au Maroc ces dernières années qu'en 2017
des centaines de jeunes du Rif dans le
nord du pays ont été arrêtés pour
certains torturés comme leader ne sert à
hautef Zafi condamné à de lourdes peines
de prison ferme pour avoir organisé des
manifestations pacifiques et surtout
anti-régime que des grandes plumes
critiques du pouvoir monarchique comme
Taoufik Bouachrine et Soulayman raï Sony
également condamné son détenu depuis des
années et que le journaliste
d'investigation au Maradi a été condamné
cette année même à 6 ans de prison ferme
après un procès qui a jugé qui a été
jugé inéquitable par les associations de
défense des droits humains Maradi auquel
d'ailleurs le NG reporter sans
frontières à décerner il y a trois jours
son prix de l'indépendance
pardon le Maroc Hélène qui se retrouve à
son tour
sur un autre sujet dans le viseur des
enquêteurs belges dans l'affaire dite du
catargate une vaste opération de
corruption présumée qui met en cause
plusieurs parlementaires européens
député européen pierre Antonio Panzeri
ainsi qu'un autre député européen
Francesco Giorgi et son assistant
parlementaire sont soupçonnés d'avoir
été je cite à la sole du Maroc d'être
intervenu politiquement auprès des
députés européens en faveur du Qatar
mais également donc du royaume chérifien
moyennant paiement la Républica autre
quotidien italien affirme que ce système
de corruption présumée pourrait avoir
été orchestré par les services de
renseignement marocain dont l'activité
d'ingérence aurait eu pour but
d’influencer les euros députés dans les
dossiers du Sahara occidental et celui
de l'immigration le journal Pauline site
de nous Yassine Mansouri le chef des
renseignements marocains et AB
qui est l'ambassadeur du Maroc en
Pologne tous deux sont soupçonnés
d'avoir été les chevilles ouvrières de
ce système d'ingérence d'après le
journal l'argent aurait été versé de la
même manière que les fonds en provenance
du Qatar via les comptes d'une ONG fight
in pionity combattre l'impunité ça ne
s'invente pas présidé par le député
italien Francesco Giorgi soit en liquide
soit sous la forme de cadeau
on ne se quitte pas là dessus Hélène à
propos de cadeaux Pauline en tout bien
tout honneur cette fois la fin de
l'année approchant c'est le moment des
étrennes et des calendriers vous avez
certainement acheté celui des éboueurs
et des pompiers mais avez-vous pensé à
celui du Vatican d'après de Times le
calendario Romano est un incontournable
des magasins touristiques et des
kiosques de la ville éternelle un
calendrier vendu pour la modique somme
de 7 européenne est signée c'est un
photographe vénitien qui dit avoir
photographié des prêtres ma foi assez
photogéniques dans les rues de Rome ou
lors de défiler religieux comme celui de
la SEMA nassana ACI les dieux du stade
donc qui a bien se tenir photo génique
dites-vous merci beaucoup Hélène et à
tout à l'heure